[Musica]
spessissimo ormai la parola
sostenibilità quasi tutti i giorni tutte
le settimane tutti i mesi Se dovessimo
fare il conto di quante volte la
sentiamo nominare
ci stupiremo probabilmente di quanto
utilizzata di più di altre parole la
sentiamo utilizzare nei nostri dialoghi
vediamo la TV sulle riviste
persino nella pubblicità però
sostenibilità è una parola come tutte le
parole in qualche modo
la puoi utilizzare per esprimere un
concetto quindi la puoi utilizzare in
maniera diversa puoi utilizzare per
esprimere un concetto positivo per
esprimere un ideale per esprimere
qualcosa di pragmatico per esprimere
un'occasione
un'opportunità a volte viene anche
utilizzata per esprimere qualcosa di
opportunistico mi ha utilizzata in
maniera opportunistica quindi non è
facile oggi parlare di sostenibilità Io
ho provato a partire da un punto di
vista
molto distante molto esterno
questa immagine la conoscete tutti la
conosciamo tutti per secoli diciamo
questa
ciò che vediamo in questa immagine è
stato oggetto di curiosità da parte di
cartografi
viaggiatori esploratori Cioè anche solo
pensare 150 anni fa 250 anni fa
questo spazio aveva dei bordi molto più
labili c'era sempre un posto nuovo da
scoprire c'era un luogo mai conosciuto
mai visitato c'era sempre qualcosa oltre
no poi negli ultimi 70 anni
abbiamo avuto questa immagine in questa
immagine ci ha fatto tutti quanti render
conto che lo spazio effettivamente è un
po' più piccolo da come ce lo
ricordavamo lo spazio del globo le
risorse forse non sono così limitate
Cioè ha preso una dimensione diversa e
se un po' vista anche questa questo
dualismo tra
umanità e pianeta
dietro questo dualismo c'è un concetto
forse un po' erroneo noi ogni tanto
pensiamo che la sostenibilità sia per il
pianeta ma il pianeta tutto sommato non
è che ha così bisogno dell'umanità
mentre l'umanità ha bisogno del pianeta
ha bisogno dell'abitat il pianeta può
esistere tranquillamente senza l'umanità
è già successo per innumerevoli ere
geologiche era un luogo magari inadatto
alla vita ma il pianeta esisteva ed
esisterà anche probabilmente senza
l'umanità Quindi passiamo da un punto di
vista che spessissimo abbiamo che è
antropocentrico la sostenibilità è per
il pianeta a un punto di vista in cui ci
fa un po' più paura
[Musica]
Mmm senza questo concetto forse il
pianeta esiste comunque ma noi
probabilmente potremmo esistere un po'
meno allora
tutte le geologiche passate da parte del
pianeta anche i momenti poco adatti alla
vita L'ultima era geologica più prossima
noi è chiamata olocene iniziata circa
11.700 anni fa
è stato un'epoca geologica
caratterizzata da una grandissima
stabilità climatica questa stabilità
climatica che è durata per tutti questi
anni ha consentito un grandissimo
proliferare della vita sulla terra
piante specie vegetali specie animali
c'è stata una grandissima proliferazione
oggi stiamo assistendo in realtà ad una
grande accelerazione negli ultimi 70
anni cent'anni vediamo questa grande
accelerazione la popolazione urbana
è aumentata sulla terra quasi
quadruplicata la nostra tecnologia ha
portato a un incremento della quantità
di anidride carbonica in ambiente
invece lo spazio diciamo incontaminato è
sostanzialmente diminuito le specie
vegetali e viventi sul nostro pianeta in
qualche modo sono sono diminuite fino ad
arrivare ad oggi
quindi assistiamo sostanzialmente ad un
area geologica in cui c'era una
grandissima stabilità climatica ad un
incremento repentino negli ultimi 100
anni tanto che
si inizia a parlare di una nuova era
geologica passiamo dall'ocene molto
stabile a questa nuova era geologica
chiamata antropocene
antropocena è un'era geologica in cui
l'uomo è diventato
esso stesso capaci di trasformare le
caratteristiche geologiche
del nostro Habitat del nostro pianeta
l'uomo è in grado di spostare più
sedimenti rocciosi minerali materiali da
una parte all'altra del pianeta di
quanto non lo faccia il vento gli agenti
atmosferici l'acqua le microblastiche le
troviamo Addirittura in Antartide che
sono che è un luogo dove l'uomo non
abita Eppure l'impronta esiste anche lì
Quindi l'uomo che possiamo dire che
acquisisce una specie di superpotere è
diventato esso stesso una forza della
natura Quando inizia l'antropocene
probabilmente nel secondo dopoguerra non
c'è una data precisa è singolare pensare
che nel 45 questo test
Ha messo l'uomo di fronte ad una nuova
capacità cioè riuscire a lavorare con la
materia nella maniera più profonda fino
nel dato più minuscolo È riuscito a
estrapolare dalla materia stessa
manipolare la materia e estrapolare una
forza quasi distruttiva
la nostra società ormai è talmente
complessa e ci rendiamo conto che
qualsiasi cosa noi facciamo l'impatto
che ha sul pianeta per via della
scalarità della nostra società è un
impatto effettivo che tende a modificare
la biosfera quando ci diciamo impatto
Zero qualche modo
non è proprio vero non è così facile
raggiungere l'impatto Zero in realtà
forse l'impatto Zero non esiste ci sarà
sempre un impatto per quanto minimo
l'impatto Zero valeva per quelle società
diciamo autosufficienti in cui quello
che era disponibile veniva utilizzato lo
scarto veniva in qualche modo
riassorbito dall'ambiente non cambiava
l'assetto dell'ambiente
la città la casa io mi occupo di
architettura di progettazione dello
spazio in generale dello spazio diciamo
non specificatamente di un oggetto
univoco
la necessità dell'uomo di abitare uno
spazio e atavica fin dalla notte dei
tempi la necessità è stata quella di
avere una copertura di essere protetti
dall'ambiente dagli agenti atmosferici
di avere un perimetro la città è un po'
un'esasperazione di questa cosa sono
tanti ambienti
privati costruiti una sull'altro
la città però in qualche modo oggi per
come la conosciamo è una delle cose meno
sostenibili che esistano probabilmente
sul nostro pianeta perché è un luogo che
produce rifiuti che vanno smaltiti che
produce inquinamento anidride carbonica
che ha bisogno di tantissima energia ma
anche un'altra peculiarità
la città presenta una presenza costante
di verticali inerti Fermi presenti
diciamo sono stati utilizzati per
costruire la città stessa c'erano
tantissima quantità di materiale
trasformato materiale
che è stato cavato in un luogo dal mondo
minato è stato trasportato in un altro
luogo del mondo quindi semilavorato
ritrasportato in un altro luogo del
mondo rilavorato e riportato in ambiente
per costruire diciamo un edificio il
nostro spazio ogni volta che
trasportiamo materiale lo cambiamo di
Stato lo Trasformiamo fondamentalmente
abbiamo bisogno di energia tutte le
volte noi utilizziamo energia negli
ultimi
50/70 anni l'impennata dell'estrazione
delle materie prime
sul nostro pianeta ha avuto una curva
che ha impennata in maniera decisamente
importante probabilmente continuerà
ancora abbiamo preso tantissima materia
prima da alcuni luoghi del mondo e li
abbiamo trasportati in altri Questo non
significa che ogni volta che estraiamo
dalla materia prima la utilizziamo la
perdiamo in realtà la spostiamo in
un'altra parte del mondo sotto una forma
diversa quindi non abbiamo perso
potenzialmente esiste ancora esiste
ancora in tantissimi oggetti che noi
utilizziamo oggi tantissimi oggetti
Fermi tantissimi oggetti che utilizziamo
Io mi ricordo quando ero molto più
piccolo che
Quando iniziavano ad esserci i primi
telefoni cellulari i primi computer
a un certo punto quando questi oggetti
tecnologici diventavano obsoleti
venivano Cambiati e sostituiti con degli
oggetti nuovi più performanti
a quei tempi l'oggetto che veniva
sostituito veniva chiamato rifiuto
tecnologico con tutte le problematiche
legate allo smaltimento
oggi la cosa è un po' cambiata tutti
questi oggetti i telefoni dismessi
I computer non sono più considerati così
com'è il tempo dei rifiuti tecnologici
ma sono considerati come delle risorse
Nel senso che contengono al loro interno
dei materiali che tradizionalmente
possono essere utilizzati per costruire
qualcosa di nuovo possono essere
riciclati le nostre città che cosa sono
in fondo c'eravamo detti contengono
tantissimo materiale inerte fermo che è
già stato trasformato
potenzialmente potrebbero essere delle
miniere a cielo aperto quindi l'idea del
riciclo l'idea di avere un edificio che
viene dismesso smantellato e ricostruito
significa creare una filiera all'interno
del quale noi possiamo cavare
direttamente nel materiale nella nostra
città non riconsiderare più un edificio
abbandonato come qualcosa di poco utile
può essere riutilizzato può essere
riutilizzato in forma anche materiale e
quindi possiamo ricostruire
dell'architettura con tantissimi
materiali riciclati e questo andando
avanti la tecnologia ce lo sta
permettendo sempre di più Riducendo il
rifiuto e riutilizzando il materiale
Esiste un problema però ogni volta che
noi prendiamo materiale lo Trasformiamo
anche solo lo trasportiamo
necessitiamo di energia l'energia
principalmente arriva dalla combustibili
fossili Quindi comunque anche solo
trasporto produce anidride carbonica che
va in ambiente quindi bellissimo
riciclare Però dietro questa filiera c'è
tutta una serie di altri problemi che
comunque
producono anidride carbonica all'interno
dell'ambiente La domanda è Ma i nostri è
difficile le nostre città sarebbero in
grado in qualche modo di
assorbire parte dell'anidride carbonica
Allora se potenzialmente noi oggi
pensassimo di non utilizzare più energia
Da fonti di combustibili fossili
Comunque avremo In ogni caso un problema
c'è troppa anidride carbonica
all'interno della nostra atmosfera
Quindi il problema non è risolto
dovremmo assorbirla
notoriamente sono le foreste gli alberi
che consigliamo come entità in grado di
assorbire la
tanti dei carbonica dall'aria gli
edifici potrebbero fare la stessa cosa
ma in realtà sembra un utopia la
risposta in qualche modo è Sì si
potrebbe fare Esistono delle tecnologie
attraverso diciamo delle macchine la
tecnologia che sono in grado di
trasformare l'anidride carbonica in
materiali diciamo solidi o anche in
forma gassosa quindi eseguire
quest'opera di Carbon capture
all'interno dell'ambiente ci sono alcune
possibilità di implementare questo tipo
di tecnologie su tutti i nostri edifici
Quindi se serve determinato tipo di
spazio per la foresta Noi dobbiamo
abbiamo costruito delle Infrastrutture
che oggi erodono questo spazio in
qualche modo le nostre città possono
essere uno spazio di
Sì può essere fatto ok ci siamo detti va
bene possiamo riciclare i materiali
c'è il problema dell'emissione delle
carbonica possiamo assorbire questa
energia carbonica e trasformarla in
materiale effettivo che può essere
riutilizzato nel ciclo produttivo siamo
riusciti forse a fare qualcosa rimane
sempre un problema di fondo per
trasformare comunque
un passaggio di stato di un materiale da
1 ad un altro abbiamo bisogno di energia
e il problema fondamentale a cui
continuiamo ad arrivare è sempre questo
Cioè fondamentalmente noi possiamo
abbiamo tantissime buone pratiche
all'interno delle nostre dei nostri
lavori di quello che facciamo tutti i
giorni della nostra individualità però
c'è sempre un problema di fondo il
problema principale oggi continua ad
essere questo
è impensabile assorbire anidride
carbonica dall'ambiente trasformarla
attraverso l'utilizzo di energia che
dobbiamo immettere quando la nostra
energia Comunque è prodotta da
combustibili fossili e quindi produce
altra anidride carbonica e sarà sempre
sbilanciato quindi la prima sfida è
sicuramente legata alla possibilità di
avere e di utilizzare energie
rinnovabili e questa è una parte
fondamentale e necessaria perché poi
tutte le volte che ci ripenso il
problema ritorna sempre lì e la domanda
è quali saranno le nostre città del
futuro il nostro scenario futuro è la
risposta è che probabilmente in questo
caso non ce l'ho però mi sono fatto
spesso delle domande su quello che è
anche il mio lavoro allora
l'architettura fondamentalmente è una
materia che ha una base una grossa base
di tecnica però di suo è una materia
umanistica nasce come una materia
analistica una materia dal pensiero
potrei fare due cose prendere tutti
tutto ciò che la tecnica la tecnologia
fornisce in questo momento metterlo
insieme e costruire l'edificio più
ecologico Di sempre l'edificio più
efficiente l'edificio più nuovo
l'edificio più performante sarebbe
sufficiente ma probabilmente in base a
quello che ci siamo detti No però
sarebbe qualcosa di che pian piano
avanza il dubbio Però è questo se
vogliamo sfruttare quella parte di
pensiero di questa materia ogni tanto mi
domando ma quando parliamo di
sostenibilità ritorniamo all'inizio Noi
abbiamo un problema di sostenibilità
perché è un problema di di Habitat cioè
la sostenibilità è il nostro Habitat la
città è comunque il nostro Habitat è la
domanda è ma ci mi devo confrontare
direttamente con la tecnica e questo
genere di costruzione ed è sufficiente
oppure c'è un pensiero interiore questo
pensiero ulteriore è legato al nostro
abito quello che viviamo tutti i giorni
cioè la possibilità di riutilizzare gli
edifici la possibilità di demolirli
l'idea di progettare un edificio lungo
il suo corso di vita e quindi progettare
anche la sua smantellabilità
la verità qual è che oggi più che mai la
necessità è di parlare di rigenerazione
urbana cioè di tutte quelle sacche di
tessuto delle nostre città un po'
marginali un po' dimenticate di
ricostituire anche una sostenibilità
sociale quindi un equilibrio per
migliorare tutto il nostro Habitat Io
credo che l'architettura in qualche modo
quello che deve fare è
ripensare o pensare al sistema in una
maniera un po' più allargata non è
l'architettura non è la progettazione
dell'edificio l'architettura la
progettazione e lo spazio può essere
anche uno spazio aperto può essere uno
spazio pubblico se funziona lo spazio
pubblico quello condiviso probabilmente
funzionerà anche l'oggetto quindi
l'aspetto va forse un po' oltre la
sostenibilità dicevamo prima una parola
forse è un concetto A volte anche un po'
individuale un po'
diciamo legato Non so all'etica
come tutte le cose legate all'etica per
quando l'etica se possa essere una cosa
generale condivisa
l'aspetto etico della sostenibilità ci
mette di fronte ad essere più aderenti o
un po' meno aderenti a quelletica è una
questione individuale spesso Almeno a me
capita di sembrare che a volte venga
vissuta così o forse io stesso l'avevo
così e la domanda di fondo che
mi pongo è perché siamo qua ancora oggi
a parlare di sostenibilità abbiamo detto
se ne parla tantissimo forse sta
diventando anche noiosa questa cosa no
rischi di dire una cosa giusta una cosa
sbagliata rischi di dire di tutto e di
niente ma perché siamo qua ancora
parlarne probabilmente siamo qua a
parlarne perché
la necessità vera che abbiamo è quella
di creare un una cultura condivisa una
cultura comune
nel momento in cui si crea una cultura
comune significa che diventa strutturale
questa cosa all'interno di una società
il fatto che diventi strutturale passa
dal fatto che una parola che magari
riguarda un aspetto individuale un
aspetto etico a quel punto diventa
sostanziale diventare realtà E allora
forse se ne parlerà meno ma se ne
parlerà meno perché probabilmente
all'interno di una cultura condivisa è
diventata realtà
oggi Forse per questo che ne parliamo
Grazie